deeply regret the disruption to patients
we've accepted in full the independent
pay-per-view body recommendations and I
think it's important now that the trade
unions do likewise so any disruption to
patients in terms of operations being
canceled is deeply regrettable and
that's why it's important we get back to
talks we look at the range of issues
that are impacting on nursing the the
consequences of the pandemic and how we
work together in the interests of
patients and that's what we prioritize
in the Hilton statement with the extra
6.6 billion pounds of funding and I urge
Pat Cullen and the RCN to do likewise to
come to those talks and focus on how we
work together in the interests of
patients you say you want to get back to
talks of the unions they're saying you
won't talk about their key demand which
is hey what's the point well I don't
think a 19 pay rise at a time when many
of your viewers are already facing cost
of living pressures is reasonable we
have an independent process that looks
at the challenges on pay and what is
Affordable and what is right for the NHS
and that independent process has made
recommendations and we've accepted those
recommendations in full and of course
that comes on top of prioritizing the
NHS last year at a time when other
public sector workers had a pay freeze
and we prioritized the NHS with the
three percent uh pay rise but it's not
just pay when I'm talking to nurses as I
am again today that they raise with me
they also talk about the the estate and
our new hospitals building program being
really important to them they talk about
frustrations often with technology and
how we need to invest more in that they
talk sometimes about some of the abuse
that they receive and issues of safety
and how we can work together to improve
safety for staff so there's a range of
issues that are raised by nurses with me
pay is a factor and that's why we have
an independent process to look at that
but there's a range of other things that
also matter to staff and I'm Keen to
work with the trade unions to address
those concerns as well these
recommendations came before
the Ukraine
respect to the pay-per-view bodies in
terms of health because of the
prioritization that we have given to the
NHS and that was also reflected in the
extra funding that we've targeted
towards the NHS so it is a key priority
of the government that's why we put an
extra 6.6 billion pounds into the NHS at
the Autumn statement and it's also why
we recognize the pressure on the NHS as
a result of those patients who are ready
to leave hospital but are unable to do
so because of social care and at the
Autumn statement the chancellor put the
biggest increase ever into social care
funding an extra two hundred thousand
domiciliary care packages over the next
two years to further take pressure off
the NHS so we are prioritizing for
funding to the NHS and to social care we
need to focus on patients and addressing
the backlogs that we have particularly
the the waiting list for operations as a
result of the pandemic and that's why
it's important that we work together and
I'm very keen to continue those talks
with the RCM and other trade unions so
we can mitigate any impact on patient
safety if
an ad will an ambulance be available
well the advice is if there is a a need
to call an ambulance people should
continue to do so and of course the GPS
continue to be open and where people
have an appointment they should continue
to attend those unless they're advised
not to do so so people should continue
to call 919 where they need an ambulance
but there will be impacts on patients as
a result of the strike action and that's
why I'm calling on the trade unions to
make good on their statements that they
will protect those with life-threatening
conditions and emergency responses
ensure we have the cover on Wednesday to
respond to those calls that's what
they've said publicly but if for example
they only allow staff to respond from
the picket line that will add further
delay to the response times which is not
in the patient's interest do you a plan
to stop these strikes this week would
you think it's too late well my door is
open I continue to have discussions with
trade unions I'm Keen to work with them
on a range of issues that they raise
with me because what staff say is once
pay is a factor and that's why we have
the independent process it's not the
only factor that impacts on staff mobile
and there's a range of other areas where
we can work together with the trade
unions to address other concerns and I'm
Keen to have those discussions
well we have an independent process in
terms of the pay-per-view body that is
the right way that we should look at
these issues and that is what the
government has done and we've accepted
those recommendations in full it's the
trade unions that are not accepting the
independent pay review process and not
accepting those pay recommendations and
I'm Keen that they do so so we can get
the discussions onto the many other
areas where we can work together and
finally do any of your cabinet
colleagues think you should be going
further and paying them more well
discussion in Covenant is always a
matter after the cabinet what the
government agrees and cabinet colleagues
agree is that we have a process around
the independent pay-per-view bodies that
is how we look at these issues in the
round and it's about getting their
balance right between what is right for
the NHS and we saw that extra investment
in the Autumn statement an extra 6.6
billion pounds into the NHS record
additional funding into social care but
there has to be balanced also with what
is Affordable to the economy as a whole
for your viewers who already face
pressures from the cost of living and a
19 pay demand Which is far in excess of
what most of your viewers themselves
were receiving is not affordable so
we've got to get that bonus right
between what is the right thing to do on
pay and what is the right thing to do in
terms of getting the the pandemic
backlogs down and really focusing in on
the needs of patients